はい それから歩きながら瞑想しましょう
で 今日はね 見るみたいね
皆様の数も多いし この歩く瞑想という世界一素晴らしい瞑想があるんです
あの日本では世界中では日本一と言った方が自分が良いんだけど
やっぱり我々は列島だからね
世界一時 素晴らしい瞑想法
歩く瞑想 何のこともないんだ
背筋を伸ばして お尻で伸ばして
胴体を固定して 手をこういう風に結ぶのです
あるいは後ろに手をこうやって結んで
背筋を伸ばして歩くんです
私はマイクを持ってますから手を結びませんが
結んで足だけ動かして歩くんです
目はここら辺まで置いておいて
右足を上げます 囲います
下ろします 左足あげます
囲みます 降ろします 右足上げます
囲みます 下ろします 左足上げます
囲みます 下ろします 右足上げます
囲みます 下ろします 止まります
回ります 右足まわします
左脚まわします 右足まわします
左腳まわします 止まります
歩きます 右足上げます
囲みます 下ろします 左足上げます
囲みます 下ろします 右足上げます
囲みます 下ろします 止まります
ただ実況中継 だから実況中継が大事です
思考しないことが大切
だからあんまりにも歩き方に気取られた気を取られなくてもいいんです
普通に歩いてください
こんなもん 実況しないで
自分ができるスピードでよろしい
こんな感じで十分 全然見たってもどうということはない
私は駅の方にも電車で三分くらいあったらがずっと歩いているんですけど
誰も全然気づかない 僕は普通に歩いているんですね
だからみんな落ち着けない方だなと思うかもしれないけど
まぁ落ちついてますよ
私はもうただあれと瞑想しているだけです
時間もったいないんだから
こういうふうにやると
これが瞑想になりますよ
そうすると そこでこの歩く瞑想は時間やってほしいんですよ
一遍で そうでないと心には影響はあまりないんです
だから時間ぐらい公園とかどこでもいい
そういう風に歩くべきである
これはジョギングでも運動でも何でもなくて purely 実況中継するんですよ
左右足上げます 囲います
下ろしますが 口ぴったりちょうどじゃないよね
左足かけます 囲います
下ろします 右足上げます
囲みます 下ろします 左足出しました
これだし それでも体の調子が良くなるからです
それがもう我々の筋肉というのは貪瞋痴が作った体でしょう
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみでしょ
大抵は だから誰いの体が最悪悪いんですよね
早く出るし 髪の手入れられるし
私も同じですよ そってますかね
私の話を で いろいろね
調子が悪いです それで時間
時間 時間 貪瞋痴のない清らかな心でいると
新しい細胞が再生していくんです
もし 年間続けてやっちゃうと
まるっきり人が変わったように体があくまで変わる
そういうわけですごいまあ世界一流の人だね
しょうがないんです ある意味いくらでもできます
その時の実況中の言葉が左足
はっきりと言って欲しい
左足上げます 囲います
降ろします 右足上げます
囲みます 下ろします これを間違ったらダメなんだ
ちょっと混乱すると左足行って右足足ね
別に失敗しても構いません
気にしないでください
なんてことじゃありません
失敗したということは混乱したということ
ということで 失敗してもめげないで
ずーっと歩く瞑想を実践してみてください
それは一つ 次 あの立って瞑想するというか
立つ瞑想があります 立つ瞑想を皆さまにやっていただきます
まず座ります 座っている方々は立つという瞑想
立つ場合はスローモーション
二 感じる 痛みとか感じるのを放っておく
三 実況中継する しかし
順番が逆です とにかく実況中継させる
とにかく実況中継 二番目
とにかく感じる  三番目にスローモーションでやる
だから重要性は実況中継は一
二は感じる 三はスロー
だからたまたま失敗しても
スローモーション失敗しても
まあ目を瞑るだけです
実況中継は失敗しない
その順番に 実況中継は 第一
二感じること 三 スロー
できれば三つも同じレベルでやった方が一番いいです
そこで立つ 立つ時は実況中継は大事に大事ですから
例えば一個ずつやるんです
右手を上げる 上げる 上げる
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 下ろす 下ろす 下ろす
私は足が弱いんだからね
下ろす 下ろす 椅子をね
取る 取る 取る 取る 左手を上げる
上げる 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
下ろす 下ろす 下ろす 取る
取る 取る それから腰を上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げられません
できませんね こうして腰を上げる
上げる 上げる 上げる 上げる
上げる 立ちます 立ちます
立ちます 立ちます 立ちます
立ちます これ とってもスローでやる
だからといって無理をしないでください
見栄張りね まあだから足が弱い方々はまあ少しちょっとだけちょこっとまあなんでもよろしいのですが
若い方々は己にスキルでやってやります
全部 ということで 足の練習です
まだあります では やりましょう
はい それでは今説明した通りに足すところまで実況中継で行ってみてください
立って終わったら 次にやること説明します
はい お願いします はい
次にやること説明します
次はとにかく実況中継でものすごく必死で真面目で大げさな仕事をだという気分で
こういう右足広げる 広げる
広げる 左足後でやってください
言いますからね 今頼んでください
左足広げる 広げる 広げる
右足広げる 広げる 広げる
左足広げる 広げるという感じで
とてもスローで肩幅ぐらい両足を広げてください
体安定すると思います
はい 起きます 実況中継が大事です
はい 広げたと思います
次 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶ 整えるという感じで実況中継して
両手こういう風に あるいはこういう風に整える
はい 起きた とてもスローでやる
早くやってももうアウト
ちっちゃい 小さなことっていうのはものすごい大きな仕事として
だからこんな感じで誰が見ててもそうじゃなくて
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ
運ぶ 運ぶ 運ぶ 整える 整える
整える 真剣にやります
はい まあ両手をそろっていてね
そろったまま止めてください
はい それで背筋を伸ばします
あ ありがとう それで体重を均等にします
これも均等にする 均等にする
均等にする 均等にする
均等にする  1 分ぐらいやってください
しながら体動かさない
両足を感じて均等になる
ぴったし均等にならなきゃダメ
こんな感じ 均等にする
均等にする 均等にする
均等にする 単語は好きな単語でいいんで
均等にするが正しいかわかりませんけどね
英語だったらバランス
バランス バランス バランス
バランス 何でも バランス
均等 均等に両足をしっかりと体重が移ります
それで背筋を伸ばす こういうやり方じゃないです
お尻の方です お尻に力入れて背筋を伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
お尻から伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす これは微妙なものです
ミリ単位 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 力はお尻と下です
上は背筋伸ばしたら力は押しから下
上は軽く 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす はい
背筋伸ばす 足の裏を感じてください
力がお尻からもう下 力入ってるでしょ
腰で伸ばしても力が下にないで足に力入っている
上は軽く それでこの力を感じてください
感覚を感じて実況しましょう
立ってます 感じています
立っています 感じています
そのやり方で10分ぐらいやるんです
一切の思考を遮断する
足の裏の感覚だけ感じて
その中に入り込むんです
それで体動かさないでください
今 柱になっているんです
体微妙に動かしちゃうとエネルギーは浪費します
いろいろ動いている方々もいますけど
止めてください 体動かさないでください
立っています 感じています
一切の思考を遮断して
足の感覚の世界に入り込むんです
はい それでは逆順番で実況中継で
スローモーションでしっかりと座ってみてください
手を外す 外す 外すとかね
まあ自由に体を動かしてください
実況中継で はい それから座って実況することにしましょう
私が言うことを皆様方は実況中継で行ってください
はい 背筋を伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばすと実況して 筋肉を使って背筋を伸ばしてください
背筋を伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
しっかり力を使ってください
あの背もたれは使わない方がよろしいんです
あんまりこの椅子はあまり良くないんですけどね
頑張ってください はい
背筋を伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす はい 次 力を抜きます
抜きます 抜きます 抜きます
はい 次 お尻から胴体を倒しましょう
倒す どんどん倒してください
いきなり倒すんです ゆっくりじゃないんです
いきなり倒す 一発で倒すんです
はい そのままいてください
次 目を閉じます 閉じます
閉じます 閉じます 閉じます
閉じます と実況してください
目を閉じて実況してください
目を閉じます 閉じます
閉じます 閉じます 閉じます
また 私が言うまで目を開けないでください
はい 次 背筋を伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 今度ゆっくり腰から上げてください
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす  はい
まっすぐになったら体を固定しますと言ってください
固定する ストップモーションに入ります
体止めます はい 次 深呼吸しましょう
お腹でやりましょう 腹式呼吸
吸います 吸います 吸います
吸います 吐きます 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます いっぱい吸って吐き出します
強引にやるんです 強引に腹式呼吸するんです
吸います 吸います 吸います
吸います 吐きます 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます 吸います
吸います 吸います 吸います
吐きます 吐きます 吐きます
吐きます 体動かさないでください
固定してください はい
深呼吸を気にしないことにしましょう
その代わりに 待ちます
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
待ちます 待ちますと実況します
リラックスしてください
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
下腹部の方を感じてみてください
待ちますと言ってください
下腹部が動いています
この動き感覚実況しましょう
言葉は膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み
縮み 膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み
縮み お腹の動きに合わせて実況してください
膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み 縮み
何か思考 妄想 雑念が割り込んできたら
妄想 妄想 妄想と3回言ってください
言ってから膨らみ 膨らみ
縮み 縮み はい では目を開けます 3
回目を開けます 開けます
開けます はい 結構です
これ座って実況中継する方法
瞑想ですね 普通の座る瞑想とはちょっと違います
勉強することたくさんあります
勉強しておきましょう
待ちますというのはどういう意味でしょうかね
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
ということは 自分の意思で何もやってはいけないんです
ただ命を放り投げちゃうんです
命を放っておけば何が起こるのかと研究するんです
何もしないでいると何が起こるのかということです
ですから 待ちます 待ちますということで
自分で何もやってはいけないことになります
それから膨らんでいる場合は
膨らみ膨らみと実況するんですが
膨らみます 縮みますと実況はいたしません
膨らみます 縮みますと実況すると自分がやったことになるんです
自分でやってはいけません
膨らみ膨らみ 縮み縮み
それから何のために実況中継するのかということは
思考を遮断するためですから
座っていると思考が入ります
必ず入ります 思考が入ると遮断してください
それが課題です 本題です
座る瞑想の本題を 課題は妄想の遮断です
それで十分です それで遮断する方法は簡単です
3回 妄想 妄想 妄想というんです
だから 思考が割り込むたびに遮断する
割り込むたびに妄想 妄想と遮断する
思考が入ったことに困らないでください
勝手に入ってもいいんです
こちらで追い出すんです
入るたびに追い出すんです
それをよく覚えて 座る瞑想の課題
本題 宿題は妄想の遮断であると覚えておいてください
妄想はやがて消えますからね
今遮断するだけで十分です
もう一つあります 皆様方はこの体を動かしちゃったんだからね
本当は座ったら体を動かしません
ストップモーションに入ります
体を動かさない場合は痛みが出るわ
かゆみが出るわ しびれるわ
そういう感覚が生まれたらそれも実況する
痛み 痛み 痛み 痛みと実況する
かゆみが出たらかゆみ
かゆみ かゆみ かゆみ かゆみで実況する
しびれたらしびれ しびれ
しびれ しびれ しびれと実況する
それだけ 感覚なら実況する
思考妄想なら遮断するということで座る瞑想です
座る瞑想というのは大体三分ぐらい行います
歩く瞑想は一時間ぐらい
はい そういうことで フルバージョンで座る瞑想をもう一度やりましょう
えーと 私が言葉を言いますので
時間の感覚も覚えてください
はい 筋肉を使って背筋を伸ばします
背筋を伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
筋肉を使います はい それ力を抜きます
抜きます 抜きます 抜きます
抜きます 抜きます はい
一発で倒す 倒す 目を閉じます
閉じます 閉じます 閉じます
閉じます 背筋を伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす
伸ばす 伸ばす 伸ばす お尻から伸ばすんです
はい 体を固定します これから置物になります
ストップモーションです
はい 深呼吸 吸います 吸います
吸います 吐きます 吐きます
吐きます お腹で腹式呼吸で強引で行ってください
吸います 吸います 吸います
吐きます 吐きます 吐きます
はい 深呼吸は放っておきましょう
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
待ちます これから自分は何もしません
待つだけ 待ちます 待ちます
待ちます 待ちます 待ちます
待ちます 待ちます 下腹部に集中しましょう
はい 膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み
縮み これから言葉に気をつけてください
膨らみ 膨らみ 縮み 縮み
雑念割り込んだら妄想
妄想 妄想 痛み 痒みが生まれたら実況します
では瞑想を終了します
私の言葉通りに実行して行ってください
深呼吸で終了します では始めてください
吸います 吸います 吸います
吸います 吐きます 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます 終わります
吸います 吸います 吸います
吸います 吐きます 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます 終わります
もう一回 吸います 吸います
吸います 吸います 吐きます
吐きます 吐きます 終わります
目を開けます 開けます
開けます はい 結構です
はい これが座って実況中継するという修行
だから歩いて一時間ぐらい歩いて修行する
十分ぐらい立って修行する
三十分程度座って修行するということで
皆様方に一人一人で瞑想実践できると思います
試してみてください これは偉大なる瞑想で
これにより優れた勝っている瞑想は存在さえもしません
これは完璧な科学的な瞑想なんです
感覚のところで心をストップさせて
力をすごく使って智慧を開発させます
で 言う通りに行ってください
成長は自動的に起こります
因縁が揃ったら結果が出ます
どうにもなりません それは
だから結果のことは心配しない
因果法則のところで頑張るのです
結果は勝手に来ます 我々は田んぼをちゃんと作って
肥料をあげて 種をまいて
雑草を取ってあげれば十分です
稲は勝手に成長して実るのです
ですから 結果困るのは無知な人
皆様も結果は置いといて
原因だけ揃うようにしてください
だから実況中継を行ってみてください
一応 瞑想実践はこれで終了にいたします
最後に慈悲の瞑想で終了しますので
えーと 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
はい 最後に回向の文という文章がございまして
できる方々は唱えてください
回向の文 仏法僧の万行に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
はい ありがとうございます
それで瞑想実践会終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
幸福でありますように
[拍手]